- Mr Simpson, let me outline
the gastric bypass surgery
procedure for you, okay?
We put the band around your stomach
so that no solid food may enter.
- Well, that's not really gastric bypass.
That's a sleeve.
- [Simpsons Doctor] You see, just like so.
- I love that there was
a cow and a pretzel.
- Very very serious operation.
You should only undergo
it as a last resort.
- Well, that's absolutely
true for gastric bypass.
They're done laparoscopically now,
which decreases healing time,
complication rate, et cetera.
But basically, you make the stomach
into a really small pouch,
reconnect the GI tract in a way
where you decrease the
amount of absorption of food.
But the interesting part
about bariatric surgery
and why we recommend it,
it's really the only form
of lasting weight loss
that we have really good evidence for.
Other ways in which people lose weight,
five to 10 years later, doesn't
seem to be as effective.
They seem to put that weight back on.
But with bariatric surgery,
the results seem to hold
in a decent amount of the cases.
- Kids, your daddy underwent
a special procedure
so he can be more
attractive to your mother.
- Well, I hope you're not doing it
just to be more attractive.
You're doing it for all
the health benefits.
- Welcome home, Marge.
- You remembered I like romance.
- Do you like guys who are attractive?
- Homey, you look good!
- All for you, baby.
- He looks like the mannequins
in the men's clothing stores
that you think the suit fits perfectly
or the peacoat fits perfectly,
and in the back, they're all pinned
and they'll never look
like that on your body.
- What are you hiding from me?
Is it chocolate?
- Uh, it used to be.
- Whoa, those buns are popping fresh.
- Wait, how did those things,
oh he pulled it to the front.
- Doctor, I'm embarrassed
to show my body to my wife
and it's all because of your surgery.
- You want me to unstaple your stomach?
- He pulled a staple remover out.
- I want you to give me
every other surgery you have
so I can look good,
and can you call it an
aortic valve replacement
so my insurance will cover it?
- No problem.
- That's insurance fraud.
- Did someone order a super stud?
Ooh, my implants feel itchy.
- Yes, I was out of silicone rubber,
so I used rolled up socks.
(crowd gasps)
- He's a monster.
Pitchforks, everyone!
- [Crowd] Monster!
- You know, we're laughing at this,
but there's been this trend of individuals
who've been injecting into
their muscles cinthol,
in order for themselves to look huge
and they've been getting
popular on TikTok.
And recently, one of the biggest names
who we've actually
reacted to on this channel
recently lost his life.
Best wishes to his family.
- Listen Homer, I gotta
be honest with you.
- You better not make me cry,
'cause I don't know where
my tear ducts are anymore.
- I appreciate you trying to
become more attractive for me,
but the truth is, I'm way
too successful for you now.
I'm getting me a trophy husband.
(Homer cries)
- There are where his tear ducts went.
- [Both] Sisters are
doing it for themselves.
- [Homer] Hey, why is this door locked?
- Oh no, it's Dad.
(Bart groans)
- Clear!
(Bart screams)
- You don't have to use defib
paddles for a back injury.
I hope that goes without saying.
- Oh, it's good for the batteries.
Now I'm afraid your son
has cracked his coccyx.
- Based on the mechanism of injury,
which is a big part of
what we do in healthcare,
we look at how the injury happened.
In fact, on professional sports sidelines,
when you work as a team doctor,
one of the doctors usually
runs over to the replay booth
to try to understand exactly
how the injury occurred,
'cause that gives us the
most amount of information
about that injury.
With what I saw happen there,
the fall on the bowling ball,
didn't look like it could
happen on the coccyx.
The way we diagnose, obviously,
one of these fractures
is through an X-ray, but just
general pain of the coccyx
is called coccydyina, for you to know.
- How long will he take to recover?
- It'll usually take weeks,
sometimes even months,
for the pain to fully go away,
and the pain initially is terrible.
You have to get one of those little donuts
to take the pressure off the
middle portion of your spine
when you're seated, and really just sit
on your ischial tuberosities.
And actually, a lot of patients
start taking non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories,
like Advil, Aleve, when they get pain
after a broken tailbone.
But some evidence has actually shown
that taking non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories
can lead to poor fracture healing.
For my patients, I try Tylenol.
If you need something stronger,
Tramadol is an option.
If people really do
request something stronger,
I say Lidocaine patch.
I love those.
(Homer gasps)
- I know CPR.
- How about check his pulse?
- That's when you do chest
compressions to a Bee Gees song.
- Yeah!
♪ How deep is your love ♪
But you should check if he's alive first.
- Are you sure it wasn't "Staying Alive"?
- Wrong song, bro.
♪ I really need to learn ♪
♪ 'Cause we're living in a ♪
Yeah, and his positioning is not great.
You wanna be on the side,
you wanna be doing it two inches deep.
♪ Breaking us down ♪
See, if he's alive,
you gotta stop doing
the chest compressions.
♪ They all should let us be ♪
The purpose of doing
the chest compressions
is to circulate the blood
'cause the heart has stopped.
If a person's talking,
their heart's beating.
- Our top story, today
Springfield will experience
a rare total eclipse of the Sun.
A solar eclipse
is like a woman breastfeeding
in a restaurant,
it's free, it's beautiful,
but under no circumstances
should you look at it.
- You don't wanna stare at an eclipse.
I mean, you don't wanna
look at the sun period
because you could damage
the part of your eye
known as the retina,
develop something known
as solar retinopathy
where you actually burn
a part of your retina.
This can happen with even
a short period of time
looking at an eclipse.
And I know people will be like,
if it's a total eclipse, it
blocks out the Sun fully,
where are you gonna get damage?
Well, guess what?
It's only a total eclipse
for a short period of time.
When it starts moving and
it's only a partial eclipse,
that's when the damage occurs.
And really, the damage
happens on the point
known as the fovea, where
you lose the central vision
and then you get disorientation
and color changes
and all of that.
- Okay people, we've hit penumbra.
Brace yourself for umbra.
- I'm gonna see it first.
- No, I'm gonna see it first.
- Yeah, looking through a pinhole,
you'll get to see the
whole thing happening
without the damage happening to your eye.
And also, people think,
oh if I just wear
sunglasses, I'll be fine.
That doesn't actually protect you,
unless they're a special type of sunglass.
- My space toy!
- Oh, it's okay, Homey.
- Bro, it's a paper towel roll.
- You can have my viewer.
- But Mom, you'll miss the eclipse.
- They'll be another one
in North Yemen in 2027.
- We'll be talking about
this together for years.
- I can't miss out.
Just one little peek.
- No, don't look!
- It's beautiful.
- No, it's gonna hurt her eyes.
(Marge screams)
All right, it's not that quick,
but there's no safe amount of time
that we would say, oh you can look at it.
- Now Marge, your eyes must
stay completely covered
for two full weeks.
- There's actually no real
treatment for solar retinopathy,
but you still would want to
go see an ophthalmologist
if you were to damage your eyes.
(suspenseful music)
Musculoskeletal injury incoming.
- Boy, I tried ordering
you, I tried punishing you,
and God help me, I even
tried reasoning with you,
and the only thing left for me to do
is jump the gorge myself.
- But Dad, you'll never make it.
- Don't you think I know that?
- Don't do it!
I won't jump anymore, I promise.
- Oh thank God!
You know boy, I don't think
I've ever felt as close to you
as I do right... (Homer screams)
- Cervical neck fracture, C collar now.
(helicopter blades whirring)
(sirens blaring)
Why not just airlift him
all the way to the hospital?
The fact that he survived
a thousand foot fall
makes me wanna study his body.
- Can I go to the
bathroom before we leave?
- We gotta get home.
I don't wanna miss inside
the actor's studio.
- But I might explode!
- Just sit back and relax.
- Oh dear God, this man's
kidneys have exploded.
- All right, they don't explode,
but what you can develop
is hydronephrosis.
Your bladder's more likely to release
and allow the urine to come out
than your kidneys are to explode.
And by not going to pee when you wanna go,
you can actually cause that
urinary stasis to continue
and develop infections in that area.
- Yeah, that's what
happens when you get older.
It's one of those natural things.
Beautiful in a way.
- Actually, his kidneys
were fine yesterday
when he had his annual checkup.
- I love that he's having
X-rays showing the kidneys
as the same visual as the spine.
No, bones and kidneys
do not line up the same.
Look at any real X-ray.
- I don't feel so good.
- Well yeah, you need
to be on dialysis, sir,
or get a kidney transplant stat.
Can't live without a kidney.
- Come on, doc.
There's gotta be something
I can do to help my dad.
- Well, you could give him a kidney.
- A kidney?
Okay, fine.
- You see, the waiting list
for a kidney is very long.
- Yeah, in America, on average,
if you are on the donor list
to get a kidney, it
usually takes a few years,
three to five years.
- Oh thank you, son!
I'll take the left one,
it's good and springy.
Though the right one's
not without its charm.
- You really can't feel
the kidneys like that.
And the fact that he has no kidneys
and he's still moving around is sus.
- Well I gotta hand it to you, Homer.
You're really brave to go
through with this operation.
- It's not an operation, Mo.
The doctor says it's just a procedure.
- No no no, making polenta,
that's a procedure.
You're talking about deadly
life-threatening surgery.
- Yeah, no it's not deadly,
but it's definitely a risk,
and you have to get
pre-operative clearances
by a family medicine doctor.
That's what I would do.
And what's interesting is
when you put in a kidney,
you don't put it in the back.
You put it in the front,
in the lower abdomen.
- The point is, with only one kidney,
you won't be able to drink
yourself stupid no more.
- I mean, you still can drink alcohol.
The idea is that you're
at a much higher risk
because you don't have a backup kidney,
so you wanna respect that kidney,
meaning you don't wanna overuse
non-steroidal anti-inflammatories.
You don't wanna consume
nephrotoxic substances.
You wanna make sure that
you're always well hydrated.
You feel me?
- Plus they'll put you
on one of those organ donor sucker lists.
Everybody who wants an eyeball or a spine
or a vestigial tail will be after you!
- I'm an organ donor, proud
organ donor, why aren't you?
Change your license today.
Can you imagine, you could
be one of the lucky people
that gets one of my organs?
Just saying.
That's better than merch.
"Hey, I got a Doctor Mike shirt."
By the way, you can get those down below.
"But hey, I got Doctor
Mike's eyeball, I win!"
- [Dan] They don't tell you
where it came from, do they?
- Dan, can I have fun with my joke?
God!
By the way, I gotta dispel that rumor
that people think that if
they get into an accident
or they're sick, that if you
go into the emergency room
and they see you're an organ donor,
they don't take good care of you.
That's absolutely false.
Zero have I ever heard
of that, and if I did,
don't you think I probably
would not make myself
an organ donor?
- What if instead of donating
one of my old worn out kidneys,
I gave Grandpa that
artificial kidney I invented.
- Homer, that was just a beer can
with a whistle glued to it.
But remember why you're doing this.
It's for your father,
the man who raised you
and nurtured you.
- It's interesting, when
you get a real transplant,
you end up having to take
immunosuppressant medication
for the rest of your life, but still,
the evidence looks like
getting the kidney transplant,
you live a longer life
than someone who has to undergo dialysis
multiple days of the week.
And odds are, you'll have
a higher quality of life
'cause you don't have to
always go for dialysis.
- I love you, son.
- I love you, Dad.
- Now don't you fellas worry.
This'll all be over.
- What's the name of
Justin Bieber's girlfriend?
Selena Gomez had a kidney
transplant from her friend, right?
(crickets chirping)
- [Dan] It rings a bell.
Also that wasn't like
10 years ago they dated?
- Excuse me, I'm still mourning the loss
of that relationship.
- What the?
We gotta get rid of that window.
- Don't worry about old Grandpa.
I'm going to a better place.
- I just don't understand
why they can't put him on dialysis.
We have a lot of patients
in the United States
who are considered end
stage renal disease.
They go on dialysis and they
don't a typically normal life,
they have a lower quality of life
'cause they have to be tied
to the dialysis center,
but they're alive.
- I'm sorry, Dad.
The way I behaved was shameful.
I guess fear made me run away,
but love made me come back.
- Bless you, son.
- Now Homer, this may
sting just a tiny bit.
- Oh, son of a.
(brakes skidding)
(Homer screams)
- He's waking up.
- Oh Homey, I'm so glad you're all right.
- Hey!
- While we were setting your broken bones
and putting your blood back in,
we helped ourselves to a kidney
and gave it to your father.
- You don't help yourself to a kidney.
You usually have to sign off on that one.
(Grandpa and Homer exclaiming)
You know what's pretty dark?
In some countries, they
actually sell organs.
That's a well known black
market for organ trade.
- I know you're a little
peeved at Grandpa, Dad,
but you've done a wonderful thing.
- Yes, you've shortened
your life significantly
so someone else can have a slight...
- He didn't shorten
his life significantly.
Come on, Marge.
- I don't need two kidneys.
I have everything I need right here.
Hmm.
- Dad, you're tickling me.
- Here's what happens
when you eat McDonald's
and only McDonald's for 30 days.
Click here to check
that out, and as always,
stay happy and healthy.
Not while eating McDonald's.